this is a special project uh dc  approached me about we wanted to kind of  explore that period between bruce wayne  as a kid and bruce wayne becoming batman  and focus on the training aspect of him  basically collecting his abilities  across the world  alfred kind of looms over this as kind  of the father figure left behind  hugo strange features prominently an  issue one but he's really kind of bruce  wayne's first enemy  lucy is a new character she's very  cat-like very reminiscent of someone  we've seen before this possible bruce  wayne is imprinting on a type that's all  i'm saying  every page from carmine is amazing his  storytelling is really tight and really  moody it really suits the story there  are a lot of classic kind of batman  books about his journey collecting those  and adding new bits to the lore  has made this pretty special i think  you